foreign
Joe is with us in Orlando Florida hi Joe
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave uh huge fan thanks for having me
how are you today better than I deserve
what's up in your world
yeah so well I want to say thanks to
that last couple for the great testimony
and for being the toughest act to follow
ever
but uh so uh you know my good news is is
that leading up into 2020 completes all
the baby steps uh was really rolling
have up to uh 75k in retirement funds as
a 32 year old
um in 2020 I got married and then we
both got master's degrees so my my big
Downer is that we actually now have 85k
in student loan debt and when I talked
to the very you know successful people
they tell me well you should start
paying that off but also no matter what
contribute to your 401k so you get the
match
um but I have a feeling you're going to
tell me that I should completely uh stop
contributing to that 401k to pay off the
debt why do you have that feeling
two times but I I haven't had to revisit
the uh the the Dave Ramsey scriptures
since 2020. so I I'm I'm calling to to
maybe get a kick in the butt and uh and
and curious what you would say to those
you know wealthy folks who took that
strategy of still contributing to their
401K while paying off debt
I would say that they are not as wealthy
as maybe they're projecting themselves
to be or that they're unusual I'll
answer that question first when we
studied the millionaires 10 167 people
who became millionaires ninety percent
of which became millionaires starting
from nothing they did not inherit money
to make the millionaires meaning they
did this uh the they built wealth the
vast majority of them there were some
that followed the plan you're talking
about but the vast majority of them uh
you know concentrated on getting rid of
debt and then used the freed up income
to build wealth with because your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income now can the way you're working it
or you're talking about working it uh
work yes it can the reason that we've
had more success than a lot of people in
uh helping people build wealth is not
because of the mathematics of this
discussion but because of the behavior
aspects of this discussion and what we
found is um and it kind of runs against
my math nerd brain but what we found is
the psychology of this whole thing is
more important than the math is you get
the psychology right the math ends up
taking care of itself here's what I mean
very few people
can be consistent and intense on three
things at once
that lack of focus
that lack of being dialed in on a
singular goal uh causes people to not
accomplish the goal so it's very
difficult to use something you said get
your master's degree
uh while running 10 marathons in a year
okay you could they're both they're both
excellent goals they're both there's
nothing wrong with both but it requires
a level of diligence and Singularity of
focus to complete Herculean tasks
and uh when you screw around with them
you end up not doing the marathons or
not doing the NBA or Worse not doing
both
because you try to do too many things at
once and so much stuff on your plate and
uh Earl Nightingale the father of
motivational speaking grandfather of
motivational speaking used to say that
uh the difficulty of achieving the goal
is not what keeps people from achieving
the goal as often as uh the things that
they try to do while they're trying to
do the goal and so all of that is my
pitch for Singularity of purpose meaning
yeah I'm stopping everything temporarily
what's your household income by the way
about a hundred and sixty thousand a
year okay so you're going to be debt
free in under two years
okay yeah if we really behaved ourselves
well I mean that that that's that I'm
presupposing that with this whole
discussion because if you don't behave
yourself in the other people's plan
doesn't work either
understood yeah I mean I was on a
three-year uh three-year plan given some
you know emergency fund expenses but
yeah you're spending you're still you're
still going out to eat you're still
going on vacations you're still screwing
around
a little bit Yeah 160 000 you ought to
be able to find 40 of it in a year
that's two years
mm-hmm really yeah it's pretty wimpy
yeah well I think it feels hard because
you've already worked through the baby
steps and you you got that pride and
that excitement in 2020 of having
everything paid off and now it's kind of
like a drag to have to go back and go oh
man we got to do this again and I love
that you called in knowing what Dave's
gonna say I mean you you already know
that you got to go back through this you
know that it's going to be hard you
you're familiar with the work and the
effort
um I think it's just really accepting
deep down that that this journey is you
know starting again that you're back in
baby step two and with that I would
encourage you to go back through FPU or
maybe even coordinate a class you know
listening to the last debt-free scream
you know they really helped other people
while they were helping themselves and
that produces motivation so I think the
biggest challenge right now is like deep
digging deep in your soul to figure out
you know how are we going to get that
but don't go lead a class if you're
going to keep doing this other plan okay
that'd be hypocritical
we don't need we don't need coordinators
half butt doing stuff okay so if you're
gonna half butt do it don't don't do the
class that doesn't work so you know
here's the thing Joe you're going to do
what you're going to do you you know
you're obviously not dumb people you
make almost a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year you both have graduate
degrees you're not dumb people you just
got to decide what the fastest right way
with the highest probability of success
in the shortest period of time is
our plan has taught 10 million people
and made more millionaires than all your
little friends are sipping their lattes
talking together put together app so you
just gotta decide who you're going to
listen to
uh this is not this I'm not a I'm not a
college professor who never made payroll
this I'm not operating on tenure here
this is real people doing real stuff 10
freaking million people have gone
through Financial Peace University there
are tens of thousands more millionaires
All Over America just because they did
exactly what we said to do now you can
decide you don't want to do that and
that doesn't mean you're dumb the other
way will work but the question is what
is the fastest right way
that has the highest probability of
success least probability of failure
along the way and it is getting rid of
this debt in under two years completely
focusing beans and rice rice and beans
you fell off the wagon you went 80 000
in debt look in the mirror and go stupid
I gotta fix this
and that's the fastest right way to
address it now you can screw around with
all these other people's plans and you
know you can watch Tick Tock and they've
all got an opinion about money but
there's a reason they're on Tick Tock
okay so think about it uh you know you
got to look at this you got to figure it
out and uh but I you know
here's the thing if I hire a personal
trainer he walks in he's got an eight
pack and I got a keg
I gotta decide if I'm gonna do his plan
or my plan
you know you just gotta say which one
I'm gonna go with here yeah and I love
what you said about very few people can
be uh consistent and intense on three
things at once you can't that is really
powerful I think a lot of people are
seeing all this get rich quick stuff out
in the market now and they think that
they can do all these things and they're
the one that's going to figure out the
strategy of how to invest in all these
cool fancy things and they're going to
pay off their debt at the same time and
then they wake up five years later and
it did not work yeah yeah I mean it's
listen that's why this whole idea of
life balance is so stupid
it just doesn't work you don't have a
quality life if every single day is
parsed out balanced across the nine
areas of your life your spiritual walk
you know your physical fitness your
marriage your kids your education your
intellect your work life you know when
you spread all those things out and try
to do them all in one day nothing gets
done
you're training for a marathon your
Bible study may end up sitting to the
side a little bit you're trying to read
through the Bible in a year you may not
end up hitting the street every day and
running five miles every day and it's
not you're gonna something something
going to trade off baby in order for you
to win at the other thing and over the
scope of your life you need to touch all
these areas but in a given day a given
week or even a given season no you're
not supposed to have life balance well
and you'll get to those goals later and
you'll get to Building Wealth you'll get
to paying off your house that's going to
come in the baby steps but be willing to
make the sacrifices and do the hard now
so that you can really win with those
goals later live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else no discipline seems Pleasant at the
time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness